stomy timeline carrière énorme taf et du
cinéma du théâtre la télé j'ai envie de
voir si les chroniqueurs connaissent
bien ton parcours
alors pour commencer avec une facile
vraie ou fausse tommy et gilles verdez
ont un point commun
tommy et gilles verdez ont un point
commun c'est vrai c'est quoi c'est pas
le point commun une drogue de joey starr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non il va parler après on va juste
sénégal ils ont le même prénom me
rappelle gilles ce comice appel chine
domine mais facebook comme ça aussi j'ai
le stum et gilles pourquoi comment
s'appelle ce tome i c'est devenu doux
stomy bugzy à ces thèmes ont autant de
danseurs et de tagguer et je sais trop
ce nom là je les trouvais avec un
rappeur de sarcelles qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle rico d'accord ouais et donc et
depuis tu as gardé chez enfin compte
enfin quoi 3g garder c'était mon danseur
déjà quand j'étais à gué j'allais pas
taguer gilles duarte les flics je les
marque un jour on a fait une connerie et
avec avec des avec des avec des potes et
on était au moins une dizaine et se sont
faits tous attrapé parce qu'il
s'appelait par leur vrai prénom philippa
milka jeanrichard sont faits tous
attrapé et moi je me suis pas fait à
travers parce que tout le monde appelait
ce tome est donc je me suis dit m'a
porté chance selon l'âge le gardon tu
l'as bien attention vrai ou faux la
première téléphone à la police n'est pas
une chance alors vrai ou faux la
première télé de stomy bugzy c'était
dans des chiffres et des lettres
non et non c'est faux destans président
rapline sur m6 en quatre on a retrouvé
les images tu as fait une interview tête
avec paty et kenzy pour l'unité
ministère a mis en garde un red bull
objecteurs conscience mon seul désir
mais jamie servir la france
ep adresse ap détroit passé il a eu son
b à c les voici qui y porte parole du
ministère justifie les maires du
ministère amer pas m
1er mai c'est un peu les chiffres et les
lettres d'ailleurs m r non merci
sion musique et rap
ouais bah ouais ça dépend et ensuite
c'est devenu agent du ministère éloquent
et radicale voilà ça change
et des fois pour moi je disais pour
rigoler ça voulait dire avec moi et
jacques ulation retardé
[Rires]
c'est une blague non mais je sais ne
vous inquiétez pas ça parce que tu
raconte pas les anecdotes de mon
anniversaire c'est mon anniversaire elle
nous a raconté que des anecdotes de ouf
mais on peut pas de l'état ne veut pas
vrai ou fausse tommy a été élu plus beau
rappeur de france car si c'est vrai bon
ça aurait pu mais il est élu plus beau
vegan de france en 2018 les plus beaux
vegan de france
alors il ya ce tome i et il ya weinheim
tournoi everest aux mines parce que
c'est vrai que nature alors tu manges
plus du tout de viande plus du tout de
poissons n'ont pas de grandes pales
amaigri de ouf la des boissons ou non un
vous avez beaucoup merci c'est pour le
rôle non j'imagine oui ça pour le pauvre
pour l'heure pour la pièce s'étire
ailleurs les jeter en prison vient des
fringues stalag au début oui et non je
m'en reste à le deal serait pas crédible
si si si ça il faut qu'il fasse encore
deux semaines de comme j'aime sa part
déjà maintenant la cassette a dit là
c'est pas comme j'aime à fait comme
j'aime le couscous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya quinze jours pour peser il a passé
il fallait pas qu'ils dépassent il a
passé d'insérer maman l'a dit mais gris
des dieux je mange pas je m'en allais je
mange pas des animaux
ouais parce que la façon dont ils sont
élevés la façon dont sont torturés dans
sept camps de concentration moi j'ai été
dans les élevages moi je suis content on
a vu des attaques avec les poulets
béjaïa d'autres ont aussi des choses que
je fais et je montre pas j'ai vu la
façon dont les ports ils sont entassés
les truies et sont renfermés
elle peut même pas se lever il ne voit
même pas la lumière du jour ces animaux
et après on fait du mal on les cultive
dans le mal et après on donne ça à
manger à nos enfants
on donne du mal à nos enfants qui nous
rend malades en plus la façon dont on
traite les animaux dans ce monde-là faut
vraiment se remettre en question en une
société complètement malade qu'est ce
que vous dites à story parce qu'il ya
plein de gens aussi je vous le dis en ce
moment il ya un truc qui revient aussi
c'est le ras-le-bol des vegan qu'est la
dictature ne gagnent 6 il ya plein de
gens qui disent ah qu'est ce que vous
dites est ce qu'il y en a quand même qui
ont tout entendu et a serré qu'à plein
de gens qui nous attend demain sans moi
effectivement il ya une sorte de
aujourd'hui on est haut dans le camp du
bien
si on mange de la viande on est une
mauvaise personne on est à quelqu'un de
méchant moi il ya aucun problème moi je
pense que si on a envie d de vega dont
peut être vegan après moi j'ai du mal
avec les donneurs de leçons et ceux qui
disent ce qu'ils veulent pas comme moi
tu connais pas bien pour toi voilà c'est
ça qui agace parce que parfois les vegan
on a le sentiment qu'ils nous donnent
des leçons de morale c'est connu les
réalités il ya encore une vidéo qui
sorti aujourd'hui encore
il faut faire des choses une profession
c'est vrai des cochons qui s'ébattent
qui sont dans les champs et on peut
parfaitement manger du cochon ma
condition que ce soit des cochons qui
ont été élevés qui ont été heureux
pendant leur vie de cochon pendant sa
[Rires]
présidence
la plupart à metz dans la débandade dans
la misère quand on demeure dans la
misère mais oui mais oui de misère
entièrement qu'est ce que tu penses tu
du flexitarisme par exemple et je suis
l'exemple de voix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le matin même temps sur la
ayrault lors à l'examen clinique
supporter toute l'excitation à partir du
moment où on réduit la viande déjà c'est
bon pour notre santé pour le bien-être
des animaux déjà c'est ça ça à bompas
c'est une bonne avancée de manger moi
[Applaudissements]
j'adore mais hélas les allait partir
elle a passé l'après midi avec moi ça là
vous étiez ni sa boule il affiche un
poids de l'or et tu crois que tu ne
viendras un beau bollénois le premier
plateau télé le premier plateau télé de
stomie c'était chez jean luc delarue
ah oui c'est vrai mais c'est vrai ça
discute oui à la regarde un bandeau sur
la tête rumeurs elmer action musique est
rare
vous êtes de garges-sarcelles vous en
êtes à votre deuxième album qui
s'appelle justement 95 1200 qui est le
code postal 95 1200 j'imagine que c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui le nom de disques
vous avez vendu aussi je vous fais pas
un an comment ça se passe de s'amarrer
au quai no 95 milles 203 nous on a vendu
d'ici deux semaines
à bientôt mais pour l'instant non 35000
pour nous laisser le temps avant j
d'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
tt sushiman cinématiques
ok à sushis mannequinat pékin express
j'avais à peine si le panthéon du
ministère kenzy et on embrasse aussi
amoureux